[Music]
welcome back to another chapter of dirty
already chapter 17 before we do anything
gonna have to go ahead and say that this
is a spoilery episode a lot of spoilers
ahead you've been warned
that's it spoilers spoilers spoilers
because we're playing as dirty Johnny
people in the comments or challenge you
to call the musty Marsten yeah I saw
that as well which I'd say that's pretty
good
that being said yeah we're playing as
John Marston and John Marston has taken
on the responsibilities of dirty Artie
he's got no shoes on he looks and smells
like [ __ ] we're gonna have to stock up
on this journey because in this episode
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go
talk to the devil yup the devil himself
yeah we think the devil himself yeah so
we think I have not seen anything like
this I guess you've seen some videos so
it should be a pretty big surprise to me
apparently you can talk to the devil in
red at redemption to you know or someone
I even talked to him I've only seen a
video and we've been talking about going
there cool so we're gonna stalk he still
on kidney beans right now we're gonna
stock up and head our way out
oh god you cigar oh whoa Oh xxx Johnny
leave me alone you don't even look like
you could pick on a goose look at this
tongue donk yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
artists
[Music]
[Laughter]
you walk out it was amazing random
losing his mind
Wow witnesses that's okay we're leaving
anyway
oh that was a wipe
[Music]
[Laughter]
you to the doctor you're not looking so
good worker nurse oh my god this is dark
mature you should take it to jacket
Abigail I just didn't question it it's
possible he didn't recognize her as a
person could've been a user go that's a
weird-looking deer did they come from
oh you are getting lighter that's the
second dome on me I'm sorry I'm late
Abigail I brought supper I wanted to
share with anyone else I wouldn't be out
here scram okay I mean no harm just a
visitor man Abigail's gonna love my
present
John you be on the road for too long
you're losing it John John where's jack
Abigail I wanna give him his new present
it's a puppet stay away from him John
he's my son Abigail Oh be quiet you
[ __ ]
why are you still talking
[Laughter]
here we are home sweet home
oh no mom range god damn it we knew it
oh [ __ ] it's prison for Abigail God
digit what you readin a Bible
will you read me that passage that
Reverend Swanson used to read you
remember that well not not really
nor do i he is despised and rejected of
men
why aren't you one of these me right now
I'm back after five days you didn't call
it but it's your name on it
I didn't hear anti swoops oh my god boy
stop reading beautiful but it's not the
same the Reverend spoke about Eagles
well I don't know much about Eagles do
you know my son was an idiot what is it
oh good you can go back to sleep now hey
Jack once you did body OH
staring contest
[Laughter]
you okay mrs. Marston sure musty Marston
has is dark is far darker than dirty
Artie yeah like he's doing some
psychological warfare on his family yeah
and you were flying so fast never mind
that guy saw you
Oh mr. devil
I think you've got the muddy MRSA the
mangy Marston mr. devil I have a body
for you mr. temple you in here the devil
is not an easy man to get to
oh yeah just throw that down first I
like this guy yeah what does dirty Artie
we just we just broke the space-time
continuum
again we're mole or something what Oh
dodo did knows dead we're back as dirty
Artie I guess must seem arson is dirty
Artie but we still need to kill the
devil we still need to go back and face
the devil we're not gonna let him win
it show us you're already time first up
here bucket dwarf pretty good already
but what I like the most is the caution
unstable sight because if there's
anything to describe dirty are you think
unstable is pretty fair I would agree
very cool I just thought this one was
cool this is John Marston and that's the
the Canadian stud 98 said this is after
he cleansed the town of Armadillo a job
well done there's another dirty dirty
Johnny muddy Marston yeah I thought that
was good one because he looks disgusting
and all those pigs are pig watching over
there yeah I put this one here from
James Mane's 8 because it looks like
Clint Eastwood saying oh oh oh Eastwood
look and I was like I see it I like it
100% no that's a dirty arty right yeah
there's cool killcam you see the sparks
flying off the gun mm-hmm him him we can
raise the aims he looks pissed and he
looks at dirty as hell yeah 30 is it oh
this one's really good this is like
serious because I'm afraid you know this
is talking about like near the end of
the game you can tell he's sick and all
but not so much dirty arty but I thought
this was good that's super awesome
reminds me of like the art style and
like Walking Dead or tell tales yeah
that's really well done that's awesome
as from kit ryan 88 and i had to include
it I was like this is yeah awesome
Poliquin they're waiting for some fresh
horse [ __ ]
definitely waiting my the only thing
that could have made this fun here is if
they named their horse something funny
but it's just Kentucky said
concentration right there that's awesome
oh this one was so great yeah this one's
really cool
one of the probably 20,000 wanted
posters that are scattered around got a
great shot with beans in his hand too so
good malpractice littering kidnapping
disturbing the peace train robbery
livestock's livestock theft
piracy and stealing some photos raccoon
hat that's awesome so good yelling at
folk eating baked beans
we also think he's a member of the
vanderlin gang but he's not been seen
with him it's really good yes I like the
donkey and the horse back there like
donkeys - own business and this guy dead
oh my god guy threw that in because
Pigman plane and fire and also that look
what he's got like a dead rabbit in his
hand for some reason I don't know I'm
getting a lot of like satanic cult life
what a skin skin donkey ears this is a
circle of all dead animals oh and this
one's really good this is really good I
know we have a dirty RT Twitter account
well we didn't make it someone made it
there's a 30 RT Twitter account which
you should follow I'll put the handle in
the video and everything but this would
make a great photo for that hunter
procedure TR d Twitter handle dinner
Twitter Oh awesome this is so awesome I
love the lighting yeah like a campfire I
just imagine like twelve dozen people
just burning lady and you come out of
the woods to this he's like would you
want
you must be real friendly with the
livestock and that's from yeehaw boa Boy
sick and that's gonna do it that's all
of them for this week awesome well thank
you guys very much for watching and stay
tuned for another episode of dirty irony
[Music]